[Musique]
alors on ne peut pas passer à côté de l'
affaire de tricherie alors olivier
chiabodo c'est un animateur qu'il y
avait beaucoup beaucoup de succès sur
tf1 c'était je crois en 1906 en quelle
année 80 81 juillet 97 comment cet égard
20 ans exactement
et c'est un garçon très sympathique qui
se retrouvaient au coeur d'une tricherie
on va le dire c'était sûr intervilles et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé françoise ben
c'était la demi finale mais il faut se
représenter qu'intervilles à l'époque
c'était une institution regardé par
jusqu'à 10 millions de téléspectateurs
donc fait olivier chiabodo et l arbitre
et à un moment du jeu c'était une finale
qui opposait le punisse le puy du fou en
ancenis et à un moment du jeu on le voit
très clairement sur les images le long
de la couture de son pantalon indiqué
avec ses doigts 3 3 la réponse 3 pour
donner la bonne réponse aux candidats du
puy du fou qui est allé en finale cette
année-là alors ça fait une histoire pas
possible il a été mis sur la touche
pendant vingt ans avec cette histoire
n'en va-t'en va-t'en va-t'en une manie
la gelée vue suite après midi il m'a dit
il a pris 20 ans danse et f1 tant qu'il
ne fait plus d'antennes ils l'ont sortie
de l'antenne tf1 va très vite ça fait 20
ans qu'il quitte l'antenne c'était une
énorme star giuly est avec cette affaire
toubon lui tombe dessus et là il a
décidé de porter plainte afin de porter
l affaire devant les tribunaux
devant les tribunaux pour harcèlement
moral alors moi je vais pas me prononcer
sur sur la sphère qui est en cours il ya
des investigations sérieuses qui sont
menées moi je vais vous raconter ce que
j'ai vu c'est un livre non pas de
dénonciation à l'époque mais un livre d'
enquêtes journalistiques et ça me fait
d'ailleurs assez plaisir de 8 de voir
que huit ans après bah finalement c'est
pas si mauvais livres puisque je
révélais le fond de la sphère le fond de
la faire c'est que en fait il ya eu de
la triche il y avait de la triche dans
ce jeu mais sans réserve il va tricher
mais là oui mais c'était une triche ga
hoole maladie c'était une triche un peu
aux institutions alors j'aime et je vais
vous dire ce qu'ils reprochent olivier
chiabodo là on a un vrai que l'histoire
tout le monde en parle et c'est fou même
vous vous devez vous dire ce que ça veut
dire que ça triche à la télé on va vous
dire tout de suite d'autres révélations
sur d'autres jeux et d'autres émissions
le truc c'est que
mine de rien il y avait des uns des
intérêts économiques et non avec les
villes on les remarque le puy du fou
ils ont fait quatre fois intervilles
olivier charbonneau me disais je sais ça
n'est jamais intervenue alors que quatre
fois ça devient de la publicité
mine de rien clandestine donc c'est un
petit peu le puy du fou on sait que
c'est un endroit très très visité
bizarrement c'est sur le puy du fou qui
a eu la tricherie donc forcément il ya
des gens qui se disent attendait et
s'ils trichent là mais il y en a même si
on dit on triche est tout le temps
évident qu'internet c'est un jeu et
c'est vraiment c'est là et c'est la
grande foire
mine de rien la quand même il ya des
intérêts économiques derrière énorme
même pour tf1 et donc lui il veut aller
au bout et il m'a dit voilà son truc
mais c'est que le grand patron le
propriétaire de tf1
il veut pas d'argent il veut juste qu'il
fasse paraître dans 5 très grands
quotidiens des excuses
voilà le concernant parce que tout le
monde a mis la faute sur lui alors que
il dit que c'est pas lui qui avait
triché mais jugé facile c'est le
lampiste si la même erreur mais lui
lourd lui ont demandé de faire un truc
qu'il a fait c'est ce qui nous est juste
parce que on est d'accord qu'intervilles
ces trucs ou à la fin c'était juste de
high tech les bras non non pas sous la
pluie oui mais au final il ya des
vérifications te permettait juste de
partir un peu en avance sur ce truc de
la voirie il voulait absolument que oui
mais et deux fois j'avais avec moi tu
avais toujours un mec qui suit c'est si
tu m avais juste un maire de l'année sûr
que ça trichet la crise et que la
question n'est pas de savoir si la
triche ou pas c est ce que c'est tf1 qui
lui a demandé de tricher et la
production ou est-ce que c'est lui qui a
nié tout seul dont je vais tricher je
vais implanter pour que le puy du fou
par exactement vous alors vous qui dites
que je suis pas que je m'engage pas
moins quand y'a des choses comme ça je
m'engage toujours pas des étendues tout
le monde me tournait le dos j'étais la
seule journaliste à l'époque à soutenir
kabuno par principe oui mais parce que
j'avais de nombreuses tragédies où il ou
ils sont tous coupables
une personne n'est coupable c'est
évidemment pas olivier jeu super s'en
suit quasiment persuadé qu' on sait que
les ventes qui lui a demandé alors moi
je pense que c'est ce que je pense pas
que ce soit la chaîne je pense que ça
arrêter la production n'ont même pas
effectivement il n'y a pas d'enjeu et la
triche pas d'enjeu la légende
économiques en jeu c'est vers cseries
qui fait 3 est ce que ça va faire gagner
votre chéri il serait là où il ya des as
tu te trompes évidemment il a
effectivement lui exécuté les ordres
dans l'oreillette maintenant la seule
question c'est est-ce que les ordonner
la production ou de la chaîne il ya des
énormes enjeux notamment sur des
producteurs et qu'on va dans une virée
sur écoute mans on peut demander des
aides à lagny
et non voilà et souvent les montants
sont énormes tu doubles ou triples ta
marge je te promets que c'est vrai et
donc évidemment si à une ville qui
donnent beaucoup plus d'argent qu'une
autre on a intérêt à la faire gagner et
à retourner dans cette ville c'est aussi
simple que ça d'argent donc maintenant
rb6 est évidemment encore michèle patron
du puy du fou c'était philippe de
villiers qui s'est évidemment très
copain avec tf1 et c'est donc pour pas
être grand devin pour se dire qu'ils
avaient des écoutes téléphoniques ont
loupé la cible et qu'ils aient un énorme
parc à ce moment là qui depuis tagoe aux
gros succès il avait besoin de publicité
j'ai du mal à croire que tous trois
heures il paraît que c'est le côté là
excusez moi vous vous êtes en train de
faire le plein on donne on donne notre
avis ils donnent leur avis a régalé le
meilleur gagne logique de marché tu peux
pas dire ah là là il s'appelle sa belle
mouillé mais dans le pédiluve je suis
niant sa ville que tu ignores que les
gens massés sous debian de l'argent en
production dans les secteurs de la
prévision des fouilles avaient d'autres
villes qui avait dérangé avait quitté la
rue du four on a fait gagner film
taillon géologique astérix
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui tf1 est très très mal très
très gênés ils veulent par ailleurs
l'attaqué pour l énonciation calomnieuse
pourquoi pour le faire taire une fois de
plus c'est parce que la chaîne a peur de
ces révélations
et moi j'ai envie qu'il dise toute la
vérité pour que ça sorte
et là c'est la chaîne qui va pas alors
idée qu'il a été menacé de mort le 13
décembre 2010 j'ai immédiatement déposé
une main courante à la police quand j'ai
alerté mes patrons personne n'a réagi ne
m'a protégé en tant que salarié alors
gérard louvin qui qu'il dénonce voilà
olivier chabot ou alors moi gérard loin
et qu'il n'a jamais triché
même dans les jeux sur les bacs il a dit
donc olivier chiabodo comme les autres
animateurs je ne faisait qu'obéir aux
ordres de la production il fallait que
le spectacle tourne vite les règles se
discuter au fur et à mesure au bord de
la piste et gérard louvin a dit tout a
été dit dans le livre de françois viaud
le jackpot des jeux télé paris en 2009
le producteur de l'émission donc gérard
louvin dit on triche est tout le temps
sur intervilles on triche est tout le
temps sur intérieur c'est ce qu'il a dit
donc c'est des petites riches parce que
il disait qu internet voilà c'était
c'est plutôt un spectacle alors à la vie
de benjamin basse sur cette affaire là
d'abord ya ya ya enquête mais moi je
vous parlais de deux patrons de la
triche mais sur le loft loft 2 par
exemple
on avait une candidate qui était la
fille de feu m et on est fier de qui
elle est l'amie de forêt ce jeu but à
caen et est en fait cette fille était
donc une mine et essayer de sortir et la
chaîne ne vous sautez pas que le colonel
soit éliminé parce qu'il ya des risques
avec les gens qui appelaient pour un
loft de loft 2 est en fait si l'on fait
alors je sais pas qui est la fessée la
production ou la chaîne mais il se
trouve que l'adp
21h10 ils ont coupé des votes alors ça
c'est très courant sur ce qu'on m'a dit
alors oui c'était courant à cette époque
est maintenant l'huissier et delà du
début à la fin et c'est lui qui ouvre
qui ferme les votes je vais vous dire ce
qui se passait exactement pour bien vous
expliquer c'est que x10 et voilà dès
qu'on a un candidat qui passe désigner
celui qui passe voit la sonas on voyait
passer mais eux sur les votes comme ça
il est sûr j'ai passé et on donne pas le
l'horaire de clôture le vote le problème
c'est que dans ce cas précis ils ont
juste pas dit que les votes des clôtures
ils ont laissé les gens téléphonaient et
ya quelqu'un qui a appelé il est tombé
sur les suivants les votes sont
clôturées à 21h15 et qu'ils ont changé
ensuite le disque donc là évidemment
c'est quand même problème certaines
manipulations sur les grèves sont
produits
chose ou pas sur secret story c'était
plus possible les règles sont
incontournables sur six lors et la
grosse angoisse sur les jeux de
téléréalité et en particulier sur celui
là c'est qu'effectivement il ya des
comptes et qu'ils sont plus forts que
les autres plus charismatiques et aussi
merde celui-là est nominé comme on peut
le sauver alors je passe toutes les fois
où les nominations ont été annulés mais
des fois on a dit ben voilà on qu'on
annule tout toutes les fois on a dit bah
alors finalement c'est alors est-ce
qu'un des candidats qui sont favorisés
est ce que dans colombien évidemment
aussi belle en examen est ce qu'il ya
des gens qui sont favoris de chaque
parcours d'achat à tulle souvenons nous
il ya quelques semaines quand j'ai dit
que que marvin qui était un candidat
emblématique seraient repêchés
il a été repêché c'est vrai parce que
c'est scénarisé parce que la production
ne peut pas se permettre de perdre
certains candidats
quand tu joues tu es l'écrit même dans
les dents les émissions au vol moi j'ai
des amis qu'on fait top chef
qu'ont fait les émissions comme ça c'est
simple afin de les émissions ou en plus
encore plus où c'est le public qui vote
il suffit de faire plus de magnéto sur
un candidat sérieux m c'est ce que tu
montres dumex parce que la notion
d'interdît cool le gars vraiment fait le
bonheur des de l'oreillette maladie il
faut que ce soit le plus du fou qui
gagne tu fais ta c'était pas ça aurait
été plus discret qui lisent le 3 le 3
mai françois c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé moi je suis assez d'accord
avec mathieu il ya vraiment quelque
chose derrière il ya je pense une
affaire dans la fait ça parce que
pendant vingt ans on a acheté son
silence c'était le prix alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé parce qu'il a été engagé
à tf1 terminer en 2016 ce lundi il est
engagé à tf1 en cdi
ils ont gardé pendant six ans il est né
placardisé c'est ce qui m'a dit oui oui
là il est dans un endroit où il ya une
manière un bureau y avait pas de fenêtre
jeu il s'occupait de développement
durable à des images qui passait dans la
trésorerie et le 20h et d'un chalutier
qui s'appelait noé qui d'ailleurs qui a
fait naufrage non c'est vraiment chiant
modo c'est l'histoire d'un homme blessé
c'est vrai et c'est ses plaies qui se
rouvrent aujourd'hui et hemani vraiment
qu'il avait vécu en enfer pendant vingt
ans c'était une énorme star et les plus
jeunes qui est mon cas je vous lis tu es
vraiment un animateur ce teen star est
nommé la figure du jour au lendemain
terminé et puis enfin entendre on n'a
pas la mesure souvent dans les plateaux
de complaisance bien ici à paris
présente on fait de l'humour sur ce
genre de
mais l'événement et c'est vrai qu'en
peut-être pas imaginé être derrière la
blessure de doigts permet c'est sûr je
trouvais ça dégueulasse ac en 2006 j'ai
failli me coûter thouars et tais toi
mais tu es toi-même tu es toi
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est vraiment étonnant et là je
vous jure que je veux vous dire vrai
truc sur la télé tous vraiment un vrai
truc que vous savez une révélation que
vous allez faire aux téléspectateurs
alors j'ai juste en amont sur lui parce
que là c'est pas une blague pour faire
genre et où il trouve que vraiment je
l'avais rencontrée je me suis dit qu'un
jour il m'avait dit je vais tout
balancer ce moment il a dit je vais tout
balancer alors qu'il était très clair le
ch ricker il avait plus une thune que tu
es un fan engagé en cdi
je trouve que sa daube un petit peu mais
on m'a dit que non emballés qu'il a été
menacé de mort etc
donc je sais pas si c'est vrai ou pas
c'est ce qui m'a dit aussi à l'époque le
cas des voies romaines
oui patrick lavallée dit oh non oui
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est bien parce que patrick collet m'a
dit eh oui seulement sa voix s'avérer
sans la tue ses frères il leur plaît et
et ouais je suis là confié la gestion
d'une société bami il a mis au placard
on va pas se mentir c'est pas le lycée
après les grosses magouilles à la télé
ce que ça triche dans les jeux mathieu
ou dans l'est tellement vrai ou dans
l'été les émissions de leurs actes et
vous avez fait la star academy vous avez
fait tout ça démarre seuil est par
exemple il ya un jeune homme qui a dit
que tout était faux dark pool alors
franchement ma star ac à moi je serais
incapable de le dire j'étais jamais en
région sait rien sur les émissions de
télé et en revanche ce qui est vrai est
ce que je peux dire c'est que comme il
faut tourner en une jours à 6 en une
journée ça de donner une quotidienne
donc c'est compliqué donc si cela va me
dis qu'ils foutent rien qui a pas grand
chose avec les loups verts ça pour moi
ce que j'ai vu et ce qui est vrai c'est
pas du trift mois des stimuli oui de
temps en temps on va dire à quelqu'un ou
à quelques bons clients
on veut dire t'es gentil il est 14h
espace rien tu rentres dans la cuisine
tu va [ __ ] la merde tu vas créer une
engueulade tu l'as manqué d'égaliser le
machin à sa gaffe tu as couché que
machin et on a beau dire sa couchette
moi ça mais on va créer en disant voilà
crémant une engueulade et on va voir les
deux trois bons clients voilà on va pas
citer on les 2/3 moqué en disant t'es
gentil va créer une engueulade cette
paix il faut qu'il se passe quelque
chose pour le quotidien maxime naturel
et tellement vrai y est évidemment des
scènes qui sont joués même chose dans
les confessions intimes parfois pour
reproduire les séquences dans big
brother par exemple il ya et l'offre
jour il ya toujours une taupe de la
production parmi les candidats il a un
contrat particulier pour soi stimuler
les candidats à l'intérieur a dit voir
des gars avec qui et la voilà exactement
vous avez révélations aujourd'hui m'a
souvent dans les jeux quand les jeux
sont lancés révision dans une grosse
chaîne par exemple ne pas prendre de
risques avec des candidats qu'ils soient
pas bon donc on prend
on pioche on est des associations de
candidat quasi professionnelle parce que
le candidat sait très bien que même
s'ils gagnent par exemple klingons rouge
et manu s'adorent arc candidat qui n'est
pas coincée elle aime à dire j'aime pas
renault et j'aime pas le rouge alors que
ils sont à quelques sur le cadeau ils
ont pour contraindre ouais c'est génial
c'est sur les candidats mais ils sont
personnelles redman et vracs solides a
également les lots mécanique
d'élimination sont faits de manière
suivante quand vous avez comme d'acquis
présenté en premier le temps de gauting
pour le premier et plus grand temps que
celui qui arrive derrière ça c'est des
arrangements qu'on fait maintenant sur
les jeux télé ce qui peut vous dire je
tenais autant l'amérique
quand on fait un jeu télé glee un quiz
on doit déposer son plan de vol c'est là
que la question une on la connaît
jusqu'à la question je sais qu'en france
et en europe d'ailleurs c'est pas que
l'on remette en france on peut les
modifier au fur et à mesure ah ouais
donc autrement dit si vous avez un corps
d'état qui excellent en séparant niveau
par géo qui est spécialisée sur la
guerre mondiale meilleure que la
question à un million d'euros il ya peu
de chances que ce soit sur ce thème là
ah oui c'est vrai ils peuvent changer au
dernier moment absolument c'est une
enfant mais c'est parce que c'est la loi
et fait un certain qu'on a on a le droit
en amérique depuis cuit chaud c'est
totalement faux
j'ai eu une enfance du manot lent qu'en
2012 la revanche des héros soupçon de
pacte secret entre quatre candidats pour
se partager les 100000 euros
à l'époque la production a démenti
certains candidats anonymes ont maintenu
leurs versions
au vu de ce qui s'est passé pour
intervilles je ne manque que l'enquêté
soit rouverte
je comprends que tu l'aies ni le plus
est-ce que vous avez une info gouin
heureux non franchement carrière je n'ai
pas d'infos mais ce que je constate en
tout cas si c'est après ce qui se dit de
part et d'autre c'est moi je suis
vraiment je regarde ça de l'extérieur
c'est que c'est quand même une
gigantesque une gigantesque mascarade
c'est ça et en fait quand on parle de ce
qui est arrivé à olivier chiabodo
qu'elle était complètement décrié qui a
été pointée du doigt et c'est alors que
imagine mal en fait un hymne et un
animateur conduite de manière ce qu'ils
sont c'est à dire combien sur la pâte
traces de bénéfice personnel on confond
pas et du coup on se dit qu'il a payé en
fait pour un système établi et j'ai
l'impression de tout autour de la table
il est entendu pour tout le monde que
c'est tout à fait ça la noria je trouve
que vous n'êtes pas là pour que le mec
et on leur a dit de faire ça le mec qui
l'animateur il y dit bon je vais le
faire j'ai pas des moindres on me
demande mon patron de me dit de faire ça
ou je sais pas qui veut demander de mec
il le fait c'est le cadreur qui a
déconné c'est un gros plan n'aurait rien
vu mais c'est ce qui m'a dit m'a dit le
réalisateur hors cadre et comme ça on
n'aura rien eu c'est vrai oui artus non
moi j'ai une info aussi mais c'est pas
sûr les sait plus sur les séries télé
mais je sais de source sûre que mimie
mathy quand elle fait ça en fait tester
les porte pas vraiment
[Applaudissements]
toujours avoir dit mon parti le jackpot
des jeux télé bon d'armes au profit de
frontier sur les tricheur manipulateur
et magouilleur alors dit nous avons des
tricheur manipulateur avec vous en dites
vous qu'il ya ben en fait voilà j'ai il
y avait j'ai parlé de koh lanta
ben oui mais c'est scénarisé comme j
vous oui oui il ya eu il ya eu des
magouilles d'antan dans koh lanta avec
raphaël qui est d'envergure les sur les
poteaux oui dans un jeu aussi il ya eu
des bas qui veut gagner des millions en
angleterre si pour gagner la collection
de dictionnaires français et on le sait
que sur les jeux quelquefois il ya des
incidents techniques que les questions
difficiles où on les place quand il ya
un candidat qui est brillant roy
chauffage fait un jeu mêlant direct
famille les battles je ne peux pas
mouillé ouija 0 ben là il ya eu zéro lui
faire toucher peut être modifié en
direct les faux pas peut pas saler la
scénarisation et la vraie triste il a
été condamné non parce que l'art est
riche à des tribus ona parlait de la
triche du siècle 1 avec bordeaux
la triche les enclos clos le débat les
chéris mais en tout cas c'est vrai qu'on
a eu des infos et je vous le dis cette
affaire hamon avait à faire grand bruit
parce qu'il ne lâchera pas et c'est vrai
que là bas je sais que dans la tour ils
sont un petit peu embêté par cette
affaire'' 1 on va on va enquêter on vous
on vous donnera des as sur des choses je
pense qu'il viendra nous voir bien sûr
avant avant les 15 prochains jours